today's topic little xanax and the shoe
and the video i don't know if you think
you want to see the video have you seen
the video i've seen i've seen
screenshots i don't know do you want to
see it
no you don't want to see louis van gaal
working on the devil
i saw a clip of that like a really short
one
and honestly the only thing i thought of
in my head when i saw it was
yeah but every it is okay people a lot
of people that i've seen
saying oh my god what about the kids
that are watching and what about
the kids that are stop putting the
people out there
like responsible for your kids okay
they your kids you're the one that's
supposed to do something about your kids
you're supposed to be monitoring what
your kids is watching or not stop
putting that
out there for people oh my god are you
such a bad example for kids
no talk to your kids if you don't want
that to be an example for your kids
that is your job as a parent not the
other person
oh my god this little girl is listening
to nicki minaj cardi b
and making the styling and all that and
i don't want these girls
yo let them women grown ass women do
what they do and you as a grown-ass
parent
survey that's your job to be about your
kids i don't even understand why
how is that that that's the thing that's
not other people to watch out for your
kids
it's you you don't want to have to sit
down with your kid and be a parent and
be like oh we're going to have a
conversation about that
okay those things that you see online um
we have to sit down and that's their job
not them they just provide entertainment
you decide what you want what kind of
entertainment you want your kids to be
entertained with
that's it i know you want a break and
you just give your ipad your iphone your
i whatever your tablets to your kids and
everything and stuff that's for you to
put a block or you to have a
conversation with your kids it's not fun
i know that's why i ain't got kids yet
it's your job
but the thing is people have problem
with with the fact that after that he
released a shoe
that was not really with nike it was not
with nike was not in collaboration with
nike
so nike's now uh going through legal
procedures but that's not
that's beside the point people were like
oh my god oh my god
i can't believe all of that satanist
and satanistic stuff because this shoe
is the 666 shoe with one drop of blood
of human blood in the soul of the shoe
uh
i'm thinking i'm just saying well you
know it's it's different than you know
a couple of drop of tears from the
children that are making them shoes but
that's besides the point right
people are mad because of the whole
symbolic there's a whole bunch of
symbolics with satan
and stuff for that oh we're indulging in
those satanist devil worshipping stuff
i was just thinking to myself if you
look at the bible itself
him just being is satanic
it's just that just just it's just
that's just
the bible doesn't like the lgbtq
community at all
let's be honest and i find it really
funny that some people no but there's
always a way
no there isn't read the goddamn book i'm
not
four i'm not with i dropped that thing a
whole long
ass time ago because of the
inconsistency of that thing but no
just being in that side of the alphabet
makes you part of the anti-program
i understand what i'm saying so right
there without the images of him twerking
and him taking the crown right there
he's cast as that
how is it a big surprise how is that a
big surprise
and let me tell you something if you
make some researches and stuff like that
and you get out of
the industrial nation that that you know
the the bible and the religion made for
you
satanists don't actually believe in
satan
yeah i know weird they do not
believe in satan the only religion
really that believes in what
not the only religion but the people
that believe in satan
christian well they don't believe in but
they believe that he exists
you know that there's it's a thing and
you have to look at why would someone be
a satanist well because you know well
made
my my research over the time and i i was
intrigued and i see that you know well
it's just satan is just viewed as the
rebel
right because he's the one that brought
the original
sin to humankind the original sin
is knowledge the first sin was knowledge
well the first thing was disobey
disobedience but it brought them
knowledge you knowing everything and all
of that depending on your perspective
god is good
or it can be bad in any situation
someone can be good or someone can be
bad
in any situation it depends how you look
for some people
god is good for some people not so good
because he forbade
adam and eve from having all this
knowledge and then you know
eve took the apple brought to you by
yours truly
satan and boom knowledge and she became
self-conscious of what she was
what she had that she was naked and
because she had knowledge
they got kicked out of the garden of
eden
that's what it was the original sin or
the second one
knowledge but everybody liked their
knowledge everybody liked their things
so by definition just him being there
and being who he is in the bible
he's already he's already anti most of
you are the entires you go to church but
you got tattoos
anti well not hentai but
sounds like what you're saying but
hentai yeah
you know french people in the ages i was
you have a
nice era abba take your breath of fresh
hair
we have to struggle with the ages but
that's pretty much what it is
you have to look at the other side i'm
not saying to you you have to indulge in
uh satan and stuff and uh but
ask your question why are you
indoctrinated
by something just something that will
thought you you're not trying to look at
the other side of things you have to
look at the other side
why would someone go in that religion
why what is their purpose no it's just
wrong it's just wrong he said he's a
saint
no he's not it's really just for clout
he hasn't said that he was
it's just because the shoe has a symbol
you know the baphomet
uh and the pentagram and you know with
yeah you know
straight up it was straight up with the
666 and the 666 shoes
so there's a lot of symbolic that he
takes from the satanist
but then again he's not but if you look
at the bible him just being
him just being just makes him that part
so most of you are actually as a matter
of fact come on now
you believe that you're not all of you
are sinners the deacon
the deacon the priests the pastors all
of that
we're all sinners that's what it's
written in the scriptures if you look at
the scripture
if you look at the scriptures come on
now
so i'm just being in the predicament
that he is being
he's he's part of that according to the
bible
so how how are you surprised symbols
symbols
truly christians that believe in satan
not really satanist
satan's is really just a an icon and
that's what it is
i'm not for it this is not a video to
push that but it's not a video to i
don't know there's a bunch of people in
the comments i'm going to go extra oh my
god
i don't care yeah oh you bro that's this
is your battle
yeah it is yeah you're just sitting in
coasting on that one
i have no thoughts on religion and
people and all this stuff you left that
whole discussion is just like it's me
you know you got one guy who's like
being extra flagrant for
visuals and attention and it's working
very well for him yeah it's making his
money
you guys are you know overreacting for
it
do you think they're overreacting
yeah exactly anyways tell us what you
think anything else no
nothing no that's all me yeah you
handled it tell us what you think in the
comments
and no this is not a way to push
satanist or whatever whatever what not
oh don't mess with knowledge
and it doesn't matter if they want no
none of that
i know it doesn't matter they're coming
for you they're coming for my ass hey
man it's all good come
i'm here for it all right let us know
what you guys think in the comments
below
[Music]
foreign